The Joe Rogan experience,
we come here,
what would you have to do to be fined if they actually are,
that's the bonus system would be jailed.
Yeah.
I mean just think about what they're doing to Julian Assange.
Right?
They're throwing that guy in a jail somewhere.
I can look good.
That embassy move.
No,
but I mean the fact that what he did was released information that everybody
found very interesting and what they did is crashed the whole fucking economy.
Right.
He was able to write that embassy idea for as long as he,
cause he's not actually in another country.
It's in London.
And I went and visited him in there.
As a matter of fact,
just briefly popped in.
So things going to happen with him.
Well think he's gonna end up serving a pretty lumpy prison sentence somewhere
isn't even,
hopefully things are going to get them on though.
Like what are they going to charge them on?
They're charging them on like hacking charges or some shit now,
which they didn't charge him on before.
Right.
Is that what's emerged?
And he's going to be extradited to this country.
Is that true?
I don't know.
Well,
I mean again,
I suppose this is what happens if you challenged the interest of the powerful,
if Trump was really Trump really wanting to get people on the side,
he pardon him.
Do you think that that would be popular?
Cause I assimilate that Edward Snowden is it sort of,
obviously I think don't put the lives of people at risk that are in compromised
military positions.
That seemed like a fairly obvious thing,
but like I don't think they did that.
No,
it doesn't.
What I understood was they got hacked and someone else released the,
the documents without the names redacted.
Yeah.
It seems to me Wiki leaks never did that.
[inaudible] it seems to qualify for hero in pretty much any way you look at it.
And he's like 26 year old person making that decision and had very brilliant,
you know,
I've heard him,
uh,
I think he was on Neil degrasse Tyson's podcast.
They talked to him.
Oh Wow.
Skype or however they did it.
But did you see in season four,
there's a bit like in that film about able to Snowden citizen for,
there's a bit where he's just come out and he's talking to the journalists are
film makers that are making the film.
It's kind,
they can find what do you with this foam,
you can't leave that like ever.
He's like in a sort of a state of mad enlightenment where he's just seeing the
truth.
If they're listening to us now,
you can't fucking have that on.
You've got to let them know like this terrifying to watch someone because you
know,
obviously now he's calmed down.
He's dealt with,
he understands that,
you know.
But he was like a person that was emerging from having seen the other side of
the Matrix.
Yeah,
many,
many.
He was deep into it.
And then when he revealed all the information,
they had a fucking,
they were had a man hunt for him.
The guy to hide out in Russia here to seek asylum in our enemy.
Yes.
The whole thing is so strange.
Yeah.
So who do our power structures actually support?
If someone tells the truth that are population they have to flee to Russia.
If someone talks about improper agricultural practices,
that's against the law.
They can be in prison.
That it starts to reveal that the state itself,
the very thing that we revere,
the very thing that we identify is the tool of our oppression.
Who want to discourage people from leaking information that makes them look
horrible.
It's that simple.
If you look at what information he leaked and what would it did,
what it,
you know what he did was he revealed things that everyone wanted to know that we
felt
were crying.
It makes me feel that it's as simple as if you knew what we do in order to keep
shit running,
you would revolt so we are never going to let you know.
Well that for me in a sense is a pass.
The stuffing we'll hold on fucking hell are you?
I thought you are elected officials.
You're one of us.
But no,
you're above us.
To the point where someone leaks information about your crimes.
They get locked in this embassy for seven years.
Like,
what is their crime exactly in comparison to the crimes that he's revealed?
Yes.
Like that's where it's crazy that when you look at the balance,
the imbalance between what his crime is and the crimes that he's revealed,
I mean,
he's revealed some staggering crimes and no one's concentrating on that.
The government is not freaking out.
We've got to,
we've left some obviously,
uh,
we have work to do,
we have corrections to make.
There's none of that talk.
There's get that guy talk.
Yeah,
that's right.
And a like a,
it's sort of under the veil of patriotism.
A lot can be concealed and that is,
uh,
an incident that passes through several administrations.
Yeah.
So like you have for seven years.
So yes.
It makes you feel,
well,
what is the,
what are the difference is,
you know,
like I kind of,
sort of a,
I've been on Bill Maher show,
I like Bill Maher.
I'm,
you know,
very simple fake tear left.
We can know that I'm ultimately beyond the left left wing.
I'm,
you know,
trying to,
my belief is that we should try and organize a system based on hallucinogenic
experience for fuck sake.
There's,
there's no party for me and I'm not even allowed the fucking hallucinogens.
So like,
so like I'm like,
you know,
I'm not a right wing person.
It's safe to say,
but like I feel that many of the problems that we're experiencing now is because
the democratic left wing liberal organizations stopped serving the people.
They were in the case of the British Labor Party,
designed or set up to serve,
they neglected them,
they abandoned them.
You know,
the white or the white working class in Britain were 50 60 years ago told,
hey,
there's this thing called Britain.
We want you to go out there and fight and die for it and give up your sons.
Get out there.
Oh,
and now they're told,
hey,
there's no such thing as a Britain.
And like,
yeah,
no wonder people are confused.
No one there.
People are baffled,
no wonder they were abandoned constituencies and despair and rage.
And I feel that in a way it's like what is patriotism resourced from a sense
that we all need to belong,
that we want to be together.
So,
you know,
look,
we're willing to believe in a fictional idea,
a flag,
and a story about,
you know,
the origin of a nation,
whether that's an old one like mine or a new one like this one.
You know,
we're willing to participate in that,
but if those values aren't real,
if I own,
like,
if it is,
we are going to support the most powerful,
we will lie to you whenever necessary.
When our lies are revealed,
will imprison,
punish,
and lie about those people.
We don't care about the most vulnerable.
What the fuck is the flag that we're waiving?
Who is it for?